vaincre les idées reçues les réticences
la peur des préjugés les personnels de
santé peuvent aussi être victimes de mal
être au travail
c'est ce que veut montrer la troisième
journée de prévention de l'hôpital
charcot
ça peut être compliqué de se sentir
fragiliser alors qu'on a une finalité
dead et d'accompagnement de quelqu'un de
vulnérable à la souffrance de soignant
va pouvoir s'exprimer
enfin va malheureusement s'exprimer sous
trois formes ce qu'on appelle et
pathologique surcharge comportementale
mental
et puis organique dépression burn-out
violence voire suicide
une enquête révèle que près de 50% des
professionnels de santé sont ou ont été
en burn out
le taux de suicide chez les médecins et
deux fois et demie supérieur à la
moyenne nationale chez les 30 65 ans la
prise de conscience des difficultés au
travail difficultés psychiques au
travail est là et émergentes dans les
années 2000 et ce n'est que dernièrement
à la suite de quelques événements
tragiques qui ont touché soit des
médecins soient des infirmiers qu'on
s'est préoccupé du problème de
souffrance au travail des étangs en
décembre 2016 marisol touraine ministre
de la santé lancé un plan d'actions 30
millions d'euros sont consacrés sur
trois ans au déploiement de services de
santé au travail